[Music]
[Music]
yeah bad weather gotta do something
right i don't know what we gonna blame
it on but watch out yeah unfortunately
it's their policy you just can't be that
intoxicated when you're flying a plane
okay i'm not that intoxicated we need
you to go to the terminal
okay chelsea just go to the terminal
okay
i'll i'll help you out you guys are good
oh man that thing kind of goes fast
i think i'm faster but
i have a
i know i know i know
totally normal right
chelsea you got to get off the doors are
going to close
negative thank you
chelsea can you do me a favor
can you roll with me to the to the main
terminal you can't hang out here it's a
secured area
i will just leave you alone
yeah follow me
follow me chelsea we'll roll out
together
chelsea i'll race you
chelsea let's just let's just roll our
little wheels
to the other side of tsa okay
because this is a secured area i gotta
have you on the other side say and then
i promise you i will leave you alone
i'm a representative of the orlando
police bar and i have been nothing
but polite and professional with you
chelsea
chelsea look at me
chelsea look look at me chelsea look at
me
[Music]
thank you
chelsea if this continues you will be
arrested
for disorderly conduct
chelsea
[Music]
[Applause]
do not resist
[Applause]
stop stop stop chelsea stop bro
chelsea you need to stop this nonsense
you need you need to
improve your behavior
chelsea stop this
chelsea stand up
chelsea stand
all right
slide in
watch your feet
[Music]
that's a deer it's a deer it's a deer
it's a deer stand down
[Music]
[Music]
i no
get the shield here
[Music]
[Music]
the door
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
check your socks
[Music]
you know what i'm not even gonna hem you
up on that you're honest with me so what
i'm gonna do i'm just gonna get rid of
it sound good you don't have any dope on
it
it's just a lizard i'm so sorry i care
about you
you forgot about it you got to yell at
her no next time let her know okay
i am so
so sorry
[Applause]
jerry you gave me a heart attack that is
not okay
do you have any other creepy critters in
your pockets no that's last night
jerry that was not cool that was not
cool well terry unfortunately you can't
keep that lizard he ran off and uh he's
going to be terry
you wanted me a fright
you're just laughing away though
[Music]
[Music]
go home
go
go home
go hey hey
hey
get back
hey
go ahead
get on the road
[Laughter]
hey
get back
get back
[Applause]
fuck
[Laughter]
you guys get on the road
[Music]
no i stopped the car and they decided to
trap them so now they're trying to give
me cuddles
hey take it easy brother
hey get back
give that
come on
get on the road
down the road
down the road
come on
guys are angry